[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tous les enfants bonsoir
nounours a été très sage aujourd'hui
oui j'ai mangé 6 assiettes de soupe
patron je descend vite le dire à mes
petits obus ils vont être très content
pour sûr
bon le seul porte à porte pour vous
c'est le nounours quand même il en a de
drôles d'idées il a apporté un jeu
bizarre il doit avoir de drôles de
fréquentation bosphore les offres
j'ai mangé cisa cieux dessous
aujourd'hui quel vilain gua c'est pas
bien des gourmands nous
moi qui croyais vous faire plaisir les
enfants
ce soir on va bien s'amuser je vous ai
apporté un jeu du tonnerre
regardez là ce qu'on va s'amuser
[Musique]
du coup au genou un chronogramme non les
enfants on va se faire une petite partie
de 421 du calcul un charmant petit jeu
des très facile
regardez moi bien c'est enfantin il
suffit de serre 421 pour gagner 1 4 1 2
1 1 en deux ou trois coups tenez
imaginez que je joue avec mon copain
bébé ça ces nounours ça c'était bon
abb
[Musique]
ça y prendre cet amour 6 43 7 g venu à
new york cinq trous du jeu dans mon art
4,31 à fond trois tracker bear 6,51 5,21
à fond
je garde le 21 mai
maintenant nous taper le casseur haber
tourner sa sé à nou lourd 2 à 6 euros
j'ai connu six courses menottes
seuls robert bret la dass tu vas trop
longs débats vers ses proches ouais tu
t'es plus mon pote tu te sens bien
tu devrais aller faire du haut doubs tu
joues mon petit nicolas non à l'ours
d'abord car je suis plus fort tous les
genres avec
magie montpetit du collant à bébert
ça fait combien sa nounou 421 c'est une
minute patrons ont fait rampon j'arrive
enfin nous on va faire dodo
ouais alors c'est bien plus marrant je
viens pas preneur au bout
on
bon
[Musique]
oui
laurent banide rapport aux nuits grosse
manette noces n'ont rien compris
bodoï
[Musique]
oui mes chers petits amis embrasser bien
fort vos parents et aller vite vite vous
coucher à te voilà grand joueur qui est
content de toi n'ont rien compris patron
on aurait peut-être le fait de jouer
tout simplement honteux coeur d'arras
mon pauvre nounours tu ne changeras
jamais se sont pas des jeux pour les
enfants
oh eh bien demain on chantera de jolies
chansons
oui bonne nuit les enfants à demain en
route d'eaunes ours net à demain
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]